hello and welcome to the android p
edition of what's new and android
security my name is Dave I leave mobile
security here at Google and in a few
minutes I'll hand over to sha twin who
is the lead security product manager for
the Android platform we have a lot of
ground to cover so we'll start with a
brief State of the Union on Android
security and then jump into all the
really cool things we've been working on
in Android security over the past year
and launching here at Android P
including secure hardware support
advancements lock screen authentication
integrity and privacy so state of the
union let's talk a little bit about what
the Android security strategy looks like
they're really three main pillars first
Google Play protect this is the malware
protection and mobile security services
that run on over 2 billion Android
devices today the second pillar is
platform engineering these are the core
operating system defenses that we build
into Android to improve security the
system such as SELinux control flow
integrity protection which we've been
investing in a lot and P and a
encryption verified boot lots of other
features the third pillar is the
security development lifecycle these are
all the programs that we put in place to
ensure a consistent high quality level
for security across the Android
ecosystem so this includes things like
testing infrastructures it also includes
our security patching programs we've
been working really hard on that a
couple of things we investing in we've
been trying to make Android just easier
to patch so Google we have a pretty
steady track record four years now every
single month delivering those patches to
the market but we want to make sure that
all Android OAM are delivering patches
regularly to their devices as well not
just Google's devices and so making
Android more modular late with projects
like treble really helped contribute
that we've also worked on building
security patching into our OEM
agreements now this will really be a
massive lead to a massive increase in
the number of devices and users
receiving regular security patches so
we're really secure we're really excited
about that but there are a couple of
also really important philosophical
principles that underlie everything we
do when it comes to security we believe
in transparency and openness because
that breeds confidence and it breeds
trust conversely a closed platform
secrecy that breeds distrust but
actually there's a really important
security advantage to being open today's
mobile devices are faced with really
sophisticated attack threats when you
have billions of users it's an
attractive target and so it deserves the
strongest possible defense with a closed
platform the defenders are the employees
of the one company that owns the
platform but with Android we have the
thousands of Googlers that wake up every
morning thinking about how best to
protect users and our platforms we have
the device manufacturers who have their
own security teams who work closely with
Google on protecting Android and its
users we have the microprocessor
manufacturers arm Intel Qualcomm
Broadcom and others also with their
security teams helping to protect
Android we have the worldwide open
source Linux community contributing to
Android security every day we have the
academic research community which simply
prefer working on open platforms so this
is a mass force multiplier in protection
and as operating systems have matured
the power of open has really become
evident to the point where today the
protective capabilities of Android are
now on par with any other mobile
platform and I strongly believe that the
power of open will accelerate those
protective capabilities for our users
going forward the other really important
philosophy that underlies our strategy
is measurability
we always look for objective independent
measurements to help not only inform the
work that we do to ensure we're
investing in the right directions but
also to measure progress and so one
example you see here is the incidence of
malware or potentially harmful
applications we call pH a on devices the
bottom curve are devices that load only
from play and the top curve our devices
don't load from sources other than play
and you can see over time it's been
reducing across all users so we are
committed to protecting users regardless
of where they get their applications
from but this is do this this
improvement is due to many things it's
it's locking down api's or permissions
over time we're constantly looking at
that and it's investing in the malware
detection engine itself today 60% of
malware is detected through machine
learning and that's been one area of big
investment for us over the past year
we've had a 50% reduction in pH a on
play and so we're really happy with the
progress but certainly we're we're not
content with where we stand today
although I will say that the odds of
loading a PHA from play is about the
same as being struck by lightning so it
is a safe place to live on your mobile
life but we're going to continue to
invest tremendously in this area another
really important measurement is the
overall ability of the operating system
to protect itself against exploitation
in any complex product there going to be
bugs but there's no reason why bugs have
to lead to exploitation to harm users
and so we work really hard on building
features and improvements that make it
Android much more difficult and
expensive to exploit so how do you
measure how well you're doing well
lots of people want to purchase exploits
there's a there's a vibrant market for
that and as they get as exploits get
more difficult of course the law of
supply and demand
the prices are going to go up and so we
watch the pricing over time and there's
a number of different markets you can
look at on
left hand side you see the met the
device manufacturers rewards programs so
the green bars are Google's rewards
programs which now are paying out the
highest rewards in the industry another
market you can look at are the elite
hacking contests like mobile pone to own
you can see on the graph on the right
the price of Android X place has risen
each year to the point where now this is
the most recent event a few months ago
the pricing for Android is on par with
other platforms and if you haven't seen
the results Android performed quite well
in that in that event another market is
the great market it's independent
researchers and brokers who will sell
exploits to the highest bidder this
market is a little bit harder to track
but we have connections to a lot of
researchers out there and again
anecdotally what we're seeing is the
price of exploitation on Android is now
as high or higher than any other
platform so this is really great we're
happy with the progress but we continue
to invest in all these areas and now
let's switch gears and talk about some
of the new emerging features in Android
P starting with the feature called
Android protected confirmation so the
problem here is if in today's secure
mobility we use mobile devices for much
more than we ever did before much more
critical things but there's still a
ceiling of trust that we haven't quite
broken through we don't vote for prime
minister or president from our phones we
don't program medical life critical
medical devices like an insulin pump
from our phones we don't have our
passports built into our phones it is
our goal to break through that ceiling
and Android protected confirmations is a
bold step in that direction I'll talk
about a few use cases medical financial
and enterprise but the key innovation
here is protected confirmation is the
first time in any major operating system
API that we now have the ability to
execute a high assurance transaction a
user transaction completely within
secured hardware running in a trusted
execution environment or te that runs
separate from the main operating system
so how does it work so an application
developers say you're a medical company
that's developing a solution for people
with diabetes and so you're you're
managing an insulin pump you want to
inject to insulin units into your
insulin pump and the application will
enable the user to select to insulin
units and then call the protection API
to transmit that data to the secure
hardware area where a completely
independent trusted user interface will
execute the interface you see here on
the screen shows the to insulin units
the user that confirms it by pressing a
button the input is guarded in this
protected area and then this entire
transaction is signed using a
cryptographic key that never leaves that
secure area this provides higher
assurance to the relying party whether
it be an insulin pump or a financial
service or enterprise that the integrity
of this data was not corrupted even if
you had root level malware it cannot
corrupt the integrity of that
transaction so in code this is really
easy we use the standard Android key
store API to create a public key we have
this new method to set the flag
confirmation required we create the
dialogue for the confirmation dialogue
using the confirmation dialog API and
then we simply call the present prompt
method to transfer control from the main
Android OS to this trusted execution
environment where the user will then
interact with that special screen really
easy so we have a number of launch
partners who've been working really
closely with us on this technology
they've been building prototypes that
they intend to you know make product
until a product in the future so Big
Foot Medical is a firm that works on
solutions for people with diabetes and
you see here an app the Big Foot
biomedical app the user is looking at
the glucose level and deciding I want to
inject one and a half insulin units uses
the app to select that then calls the
API to invoke the new user interface
that you see there the user confirms and
then in only then will the insulin pump
administer
dose in the medical side we have Royal
Bank Canada RBC that is working to
integrate protected confirmations into
their application I don't have a video
for this one but you can track left to
right this application is moving a
person-to-person financial transfer we
see we're going to send $1,500 to Ravi
the application invokes the protected
confirmations API which you see in the
middle the user confirms 1500 so 1500
can't be changed to 15000 the relying
party on the other end has high
confidence that indeed we intended to
send Ravi $1500 and the transaction goes
through duo security is a firm that's
working on strong Enterprise
authentication imagine you're logging in
to your Chromebook into your G suite
application and it launches a second
factor authentication to your phone you
see the request come in on the left the
application duo securities application
comes up and ask for confirmation but
then there's the second level
confirmation using the protected
confirmation API that provides again
higher level of assurance it's for the
enterprise that it is the device and
user and location that's expected for
that authentication so there are a lot
of other launch partners we've worked
closely with on this in select
corporation is also integrating their
application for control of diabetes
procs to me is doing proximal based
authentication knock-knock labs in the
enterprise authentication space as well
I'd also like to throw a shout-out to
Qualcomm we've been working really
closely with Qualcomm to integrate the
protected confirmations API into the
next generation Qualcomm chip sets
because protected confirmations requires
a deep integration at the hardware level
it is optional for P and so it requires
a supported Android P device we're
breaking through that last sealing of
assurance in mobility so it's very
exciting there's a lot more to talk
about and so I'd like to now call up sha
when to take us through the story
thanks Dave
good morning everyone and I'm really
excited to be here to talk about a lot
more the security and privacy features
that we built into Android P so as
they've mentioned secure hardware is a
huge focus for area for us because they
can provide defenses against attacks
that software alone is simply not
sufficient to handle and so protecting
confirmation with an API that really
leveraged secure hardware and another
API another feature that we're making in
Android P it leverages secure Hardware
also to provide stronger protection for
private keys so why do we need stronger
protection for private keys well Google
Page Transit is a great example here and
in fact we're working closely with them
on this P feature and they're going to
launch with it later this year consider
their security goal and the traditional
transit use case they need to make sure
that your transit card and only your
transit card can be used to pay for your
bus ride so your transit card has your
account information or a lot of secrets
and there that represents your account
now the transit card is it's simply made
using a secure element inside of it so
it's very hard to break into it extract
secrets out of it and duplicate that
card so and repay transit is now working
to replace that transit card with your
phone and so we need to make sure that
we provide the same security guarantees
which is that your secrets cannot be
extracted out of your phone and put onto
another phone so in order to pay for
your bus ride you must present your
phone and a great solution here is used
to care hardware
now Google pay transit is one example of
an in-person transaction payments at
another in all of these use cases you
want to make sure that your phone and
only your phone can make that
transaction there are quite a few other
examples where we we benefit from
stronger protection for private keys for
example if you have high value cloud
data if you have if you're an enterprise
or if you are a financial institution
you want to make sure that all requests
all data access
coming from a known phone a phone that
you trust and that phone is identified
by a private key also if you have high
value local data let's or let's say your
password manager you're storing
passwords locally on disk then you may
want to encrypt it again with a private
key that's well protected and so how do
we provide stronger protection with
private keys
traditionally secure elements such as
those built-ins - smart card credit
cards and second factor security keys
and transit cards are the gold standard
for hardware security they're built to
exacting standards and certified by
professional labs to be resistant to
Hardware tampering and phones are now
starting to incorporate that exact
hardware directly into the phone so that
your phone can replace your transit card
replace your credit card and we placed
your a second factor security key and so
with Android P we're now exposing api's
so that all applications on Android can
take advantage of this type of tamper
resistant Hardware on compatible devices
and potentially enable a brand new use
cases specifically we're adding a new
type of key store called strongbox
strongbox is built using in tamper
resistant hardware and like a secure
elements that has isolated CPU RAM and
secure storage now the fact that it has
its own dedicated CPU and RAM is pretty
important because it makes it so that
it's resistant to shared resource
attacks for example many of the high
profile Hardware chunks that we've heard
about recently strongboxes resistant to
those as well as resistant to
side-channel attacks like timing attacks
as well as physical attacks like
glitching the power line so when we look
at the keystore types that are available
in android there are now three types of
keystore the on older Android devices
kisora was typically implemented using
the Android operating system directly on
new Android devices that shipped with
Android nougat and above keystore was
implemented using the TE the trust of
execution of marvin and now with Android
P we're providing a new key store called
strongbox that can run alongside it
together with the existing key store in
the TE
strongboxes resistant to the widest
variety of attacks and is really
well-suited if you have a use case that
requires strong protection for your
private keys now the caveat here is that
because it does require new hardware
strong-box will be available on only
some new devices that shipped with
Android P to use strongbox it's fairly
straightforward when you create your key
store key set a new flag to request that
the key be backed by strongbox if the
device supports strongbox then
everything succeeds and goes well if the
device does not support strongbox you'll
get a strongbox unavailable exception so
to summarize strongbox is implemented
using tamper resistant hardware like a
secure element to your elements are the
gold standard for hardware security and
this is the first time that we're
offering a generic API to access this
type of secure Hardware on four key
management this feature as well as the
protected conformation API are really
pushing the boundary for secure hardware
support on mobile and we're really
excited about the use cases that this
enables so protecting your private keys
is one thing that apps need to do
another thing that apps often need to do
is to make sure that the right user is
present when you look at a typical
Android device especially one that's up
to date and fully patched the most
likely security incident to happen to
that device is not malware but rather
getting lost or stolen and so a lock
screen is very important for Android
make sure you set a lock screen and also
as an app developer make sure that you
do gate sensitive access on user
presence on user authentication so an
Android P we added a few different
features to help out developers do that
starting with key Gore bound keys key
car bound keys are key store keys that
are well suited for protecting very
sensitive data use that you store
directly on the device like the name
implies key guard bound keys have their
functionality tied to the key guard
which is the lock screen on Android and
so these keys can be used to encrypt
data
at any time and can be used to decrypt
data only when the device is unlocked
and so the lifecycle of these keys are
tied to the lifecycle of the lock screen
for example if you have very sensitive
very confidential enterprise data or
very private health and fitness data you
might want to encrypt it with a key or
bound key before you store it to disk so
that if the device does get lost or
stolen as long as there's a lock screen
on that device it's now a little bit
harder for an attacker to access the
sensitive data to use a key or bound key
it's also fairly straightforward when
you create your key store key set a flag
to require that the device be unlocked
to use it for decryption then when you
create your cipher objects you can
create it for encryption at any time and
you can create it for decryption and
only when the device is all marked so
fairly straightforward fairly simple now
what if your device has been properly
unlocked but you want to check for user
authentication and one more time let's
say before a very sensitive action like
a payment happens this is where
biometric prompt comes in biometric
prompt is our replacement for
fingerprint manager now a lot of apps
today are using fingerprint manager to
Rihanna Kate the user using fingerprints
one more time now fingerprint manager
had a few limitations one is it only
works for fingerprint a lot of devices
today are starting to support face iris
and other biometric modalities and so
with biometric prompts we do support
more than just fingerprint we support
several different modalities and it will
automatically pick the right modality
for that user and for that device
another benefit of biometric prompt is
that it uses standard system you are
which is really nice from a user
experience perspective to show the user
a standard UI when they were making a
security irrelevant decision also it
sets us up well for future advances and
sensor technology when you have for
example in in display a fingerprint
sensor it's much easier for the OEM to
customize this UI to tell the user
exactly where to put their finger and
less scalable for an app to have to
create to my specific key
we know that biometric prompt is quite a
bit quite different from fingerprint
manager and so to ease the pain of
migration we're also providing a support
library and so apps will be able to call
the one API not support library and that
will use biometric prompt on Android P
devices and fall back gracefully to
fingerprint manager on older devices to
use biometric prompts create the Builder
object and pass it the title and
subtitle in these kinds of properties
then call the authenticate method on the
prompt to create to show the
authentication and prompt we do
recommend that you pass in the crypto
objects because that's how you tie
successful authentication attempts to a
subsequent cryptographic operation all
right so biometric prompt works really
well when your user is trying to
authenticate to your native Android app
now what if the user is actually going
to your website and Chrome how do you
authenticate them there this is where
web a thin and vital to come in camellia
later this year in q4 chrome on Android
it will support web often which means if
the user is going to your website they
can now use their lock screen or their
biometric signals to authenticate to
your website and I think this is very
useful because for example if you like
to buy things on the web
paypal now actually has a demo running
where you can use your fingerprints to
authenticate to PayPal and use that to
to purchase your to make your purchase
and so that's a lot more convenient than
typing in your password
every time you go to PayPal to make a
purchase on the web so then to summarize
the several different methods that we
talked about to gate access based on
authentication first with key car bound
keys you can tie data access to the
lifecycle the lock screen if the user
has already unlocked the screen you and
you want to real authentic ticket the
user then you can use biometric prompt
to show the system UI to prompt for
biometric
and finally if the user is going to your
website instead of your native app you
can use web often to authenticate the
user via fingerprint and chrome on
Android okay now that you've determined
it to the right user let's switch gears
one more time to talk about integrity a
lot of apps really need to make sure
that really indeed you ensure the
integrity of their data as well as the
integrity of the device that they're
running on so how do we do this an
Android pee to help you protect the
integrity of your data in transit we're
going to require TLS by default so for
all new apps that target the pee API
level if the system will throw an
exception if the app sends data in the
clear using TLS should be a no-brainer
for apps today because it protects the
privacy of your users and it also
protects your content from being
modified in transit whether it's being
whether it's injection of unwanted ads
or injection of tracking identifiers or
especially formatted data to exploit a
weakness in your app so you should
always encrypt now if you're connecting
to a legacy website that has not
migrated to TLS yet then you can still
opt out of specific domains by updating
your network security config so do visit
the website on the slide to learn more
about customizing TLS enforcement for
your app now before you run off to
change your code we have one more piece
of good news for a lot of apps care
about v cryptographic compliance because
it's really important in reading the
regulated industries and the government
so we're really happy that boring SSL
which is used to secure SSL traffic on
Android recently received C AVP
certificates from NIST for many Phipps
approved algorithms and so this means
that developers targeting regulated
industries now basically have automatic
fixed compliance built in and so we're
very excited about that all right so
another topic is in the integrity
section that developers often care about
is how do I make sure that the device
itself has not been tampered with the
of ice itself is still healthy in
Android we introduced a feature called
key attestation and it's been updated in
android p piazza station allows you to
get a signed statement directly from the
secure hardware itself from strongbox
from te about the state of the device
and about the properties of your private
keys so for example piazza station can
tell you whether the device passed
verified boots
whether it's running a recent security
patch whether the your private keys are
protected by te or strongbox
another thing that piazza station will
return to you on compatible devices on
android p is the firmware hash that the
device is running so this is the digest
of the operating system that you're
running at this time think of this as
transparency enabled verified food what
this means is if you're running a
firmware digest that's the same as that
of a known good version then you're
actually running a bit for bit identical
version of the operating system as that
known good version so that's a really
powerful thing to know about what you're
running and it's really important for a
tightly controlled environment like
enterprises to know that the operating
system that you're running is an exact
copy of a known good version for users
of the safety net attestation APR the
implementation of that will call the
platform chaos cessation api under the
hood so you will be able to take
advantage of this without any changes to
your code now in some cases if you want
to get more information from the api
then what's returned by safety net you
can still call the kyoto station APR
directly now last but certainly not
least privacy privacy is an important
area to security we actually talked
about privacy quite a bit already when
we talked about for example the TLS by
default feature coming in android but
there are a few other privacy features
that there are an age or p that we want
to cover now first this is probably one
of my favorite features sensor access
only in the foreground in Android P
running on an Android P device
regardless of your API level
if your app is in the background and
idle you will no longer be able to
access the camera microphone or sensors
this behavior now is slightly different
based on the exact characteristics of
the API that you're targeting so for
example the mic with a microphone API
you won't be able to you will you will
get silence when you try to access
microphone from the background and idle
with a camera API it'll behave as if you
were preempted by a higher priority
camera client with sensors it depends on
whether the sensor returns data
continuously or via callback the bottom
line is that if your app is in the
background and idle you can no longer
access user data from sensors now if you
need to access the camera microphone or
sensors and you're in the background
create a foreground service with a
persistent user visible notification so
that gives users a lot more control and
more transparency into which apps have
their access to their sensors at that
time to start a foreground service
create that persistent notification
first and then call the start foreground
method and pass it in passing that
notification all right
besides background access to sensors
restricting background access to sensors
we've also added a lot more user control
over your data so Android it's the first
major operating system to have DNS over
TLS support built right in and so your
DNS queries will be redirected to a
trusted resolver of your choice that
means that third parties on the web can
no longer monitor or manipulate your DNS
traffic now if your DNS if your default
DNS resolvers already supports it then
we will automatically encrypt your data
we did this in collaboration with
alphabets jigsaw team who are working on
many other initiatives in this area and
so we're really looking forward to many
new developments here another cool
feature that we added an Android pee in
the privacy space is lockdown mode
so lockdown mode is useful if you're in
a situation where you may temporarily
lose access
to your to your device let's say you
need to hand it over for inspection at a
security checkpoint so at that time you
can put your device into lockdown mode
which is which is it now in a state
where only your knowledge factor your
pimp and password can be used to unlock
the device and so your fingerprint and
other biometrics will be disabled your
smart lock will be disabled in fact
notifications will no longer show on the
lock screen so you now have much more
higher much higher assurances on the
state of the lock screen on the security
of the lock screen when the device is
temporarily out of sight so that was a
quick overview of the features that are
coming with Android P there's a lot more
that we didn't have time to cover and so
please do give us your feedback at
google.com slash IO / schedule and send
us email security at Android comm thank
you for coming
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]